- I feel like it's gonna
be a great experience.
No, not at all. (laughs)
(peppy string music)
- Today we're gonna shave my legs.
I'm not looking forward
to it, very afraid.
- I'm actually excited
about this, is that weird?
How do women do it?
- I've got a lot of hair, it's been
buildin' up for 25 years.
Maybe at the end of this, I'll have
nicer shaved legs than my girlfriend.
- All right, let's do this, do, how, do,
I don't even know what I'm doing. (laughs)
- Ooh.
- That's kinda gross.
Gotta really get up there.
- Now the fun part begins.
I don't know if I'm supposed to go
like, against the grain or with it.
- Clean strokes, clean strokes.
- I feel like I'm like,
husking corn or something.
- Look at this, this is
the first clean spot.
Oh my God. (chuckles)
- Ooh, damn, that's smooth.
- How do ladies get the back of the leg?
That's what I'm, like, confused about,
'cause I can't see it and I don't have
the yoga capabilities to like,
twist my body back there.
- I think I might have
just nicked somethin'
back here, maybe.
- Oh, it feels so weird.
- Look at the difference, look at, like,
just the, the tan looking difference.
- It doesn't feel like my leg,
you know what it feels like?
It feels like a piece of chicken.
- I'm likin' the results.
- Calf is looking great.
- It's just so oily.
- It's like, sexy lady, hairy man.
- Oh God, I'm like, over it already.
This is a long process.
- (chuckling) This is gonna take forever.
I feel like I'm gonna
cut myself on my knee.
- Okay, we have our first sign of blood.
A little, little toe cut action.
- I also just found a freckle
that I didn't know I had.
- Oh, and there's like, giant patches
that I guess I've just,
like, forgotten about.
- Like, shaving your legs,
it's such a build up,
and then it's just
(grunting) a lot of work,
just get off!
- All right, how do I look?
- All right, give a little turn,
give a little turn, yeah.
- All right, that took
a span of, like, what?
Four, 20, 40 minutes?
- I feel like my legs look weird,
they just look like these hot dogs.
- I will say, feeling it
now, it feels kinda good.
- Ooh, I've got a nice gloss though.
Look at that, look at the way
the light, like, reflects.
- I've underestimated how
long it takes to shave legs.
- The process is straight
up a pain in the ass.
- If I was a girl and I
had to do this every day,
I'd probably just wear
pants and not do it.
- I'm kinda scared to see
what happens when it grows in.
- So, this is three days later.
- This whole weekend it was just itchy.
Like, I felt like I had an
allergic reaction to shaving.
- It's been very sensitive, I've been,
my legs are crazy sensitive.
- Someone told me that it would
feel good against the
sheets, and it does not.
- I wore shorts over the weekend,
and just because, when I sweat,
it felt weird on my jeans.
- And then you realize
you like, missed patches,
and you look gross.
- I will say this,
though, showers have been
increasingly easier, like with drying,
it's just like, whoop.
- I am getting stubs, I'm
getting mad stubs right now.
- I think this has made me realize
just how ridiculous this pressure is,
and if somebody's not into you
because you have hairy legs,
then they can just move along.
Just think about all,
like, the other things
you could be doing to your life
except for shaving your
legs, you could like,
go to the gym, you could cure cancer,
you could get a new pet.